all right now you guys doing huh all
right why names Nick it's good to be
here I'm excited I just got new shoes
for tonight for tonight's performance
and I went and bought them and I went to
the shoe store and it was weird cuz I
had all these different like categories
for the shoes like they had basketball
shoes and tennis shoes and running shoes
and one of the sections I had was
adventure was one of the kind of shoes I
know that was weird cuz like I could see
people going in you know like yeah I
played out a basketball do you guys have
a good basketball shoe or yeah I played
a lot of tennis you have a comfortable
tennis shoe but like how many people
seriously walk in like yeah hi I'm gonna
be rescuing a princess
over the next six months I want you know
she's on a mountain guarded by dragons
so if you have like a fireproof sandal
do you have size tips I'm traveling with
elves and they all need shoes so I got
that going for me I uh I'm also I also
kind of in a sad mood because I took my
cat to the veterinarian today because my
cat had diarrhea and the vet was like
what have you been feeding him and I'm
like diarrhea
it's not bad I also I just soared an
album off TV which I'm very excited
about it uh sounds of the 80s off the
late-night television oh my god because
you know it's obvious I like to party
and but when I got it it was sound to
the 1580s there was no music on the
whole thing it was just this one guy
he's like winter's coming again we don't
have much time
fathers got smallpox he's not gonna make
it I know it we've got to find food
where the horses I can't feel my legs
I'm like I can't dance to that what the
heck is going on
do they have a remix of my can't feel my
legs so I don't really want a lot out of
life you know I really just want to get
through life without getting stabbed
absolutely all it boils down to for me
like I don't care if I don't save a
million people or care anything just
please don't stab me that's like if I'm
in heaven and I haven't been stabbed I
win that's how I see cuz it's not like
getting shot like getting stabbed is so
horrible like when you get shot it's
like you don't see the bullet going in
you're just hanging out you're like
alright what's up whoa oh I just got
shot like when you get stabbed like
you're there the whole time you're just
watching it happen No thank you to that
whole process I could avoid that that'd
be just great what else I'm not I'm not
afraid of getting older though like a
lot of my friends I'll freak that by
getting old cuz I just I just spent the
last week with my grandma she just
turned 90 years old 90 that sold and and
I didn't throw the sheets or ninety I
was like when I turn my grandma hole too
you know and she was like ninety and I
was like oh but it's like what do you
say to that you know I'm like you look
like you're 80 you don't even look 90
grandma easily maybe even 79 but I love
hanging out with my grandma though I
love spending time with her she's
physically she's really weak so it's
cool hanging out with her kosoul my but
when I hang out with her I feel strong
it's great hang out with old people you
know my grandmas always like can you
help me with this gallon of milk right
here this gallon of milk I'm like what
do you mean this gallon right here
[Applause]
[Music]
you're the strongest boy in the world
Ramy you look tired why don't you sit
down on this stool you should fight
crime all right you guys
[Applause]